les français regarde-t-il la cinquième
chaîne dans l'ensemble non puisque un
français sur cinq seulement la reçoit
l'as regarde-t-il beaucoup après un
démarrage en fanfare et à succès de
curiosité l'audience est stabilisée aux
alentours de 13% avec une moyenne des
coûts de 40 minutes par jour dont un
taux important consacré aux rediffusion
c'est un résultat moyen mais dont les
promoteurs de la sec se déclarent très
satisfaits d'autant que sous semble
idyllique avec les publicitaires
résultat ils augmentent leurs tarifs et
annonce 230 millions de francs déjà
récolté cependant les critiques qu'on
était souvent très virulente sur la
qualité des programmes
ceci devrait changer un peu avec un film
supplémentaire des flashes d'information
au moins deux rediffusions pour
septembre silvio berlusconi affirme
avoir des accords secrets avec de
grandes vedettes
il rappelle enfin pour se défendre qu'il
n'avait eu que 40 jours pour monter
cette nouvelle chaîne privée